معاينه اخيره يجريها سائق هذه الشاحنه
استعدادا لرحله تجاريه افريقيه طويله
يا رب السلامه رحله بعد اخرى وعلى مدى 30
سنه تراكمت لديه خبره التجاره والطريق
حتى الحدود الكركارات ما عندناش المشكل في
الطريق البنيه التحتيه
كلها الطريق دابا ولات مزيانه اللهم صلي
عليك يا رسول الله بالنسبه
للموريتانيا بالنسبه للسنغال
كلشي دابا كيدير البنيه التحتيه
انتهت الاشغال في اغلب مقاطع طريق سريع
مزدوج يمتد 1000 كيلومتر بين مدينتي
اكادير والداخله جنوبا باتجاه افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء سيعزز الطريق تبادلات المغرب
التجاريه مع دول القاره
والمغرب من البلدان الموقعه على اتفاقيه
منطقه التجاره الحره القاريه الافريقيه
وعبر ميناء طنجه احد اكبر موانئ البحر
الابيض المتوسط يعبر 40% من اعاده الشحن
نحو دول افريقيه
اتفاقيه منطقه التجاره الحره القاريه
الافريقيه دخلت حيز التنفيذ قبل عامين
وتنص على تحرير التجاره في معظم التعاملات
التجاريه بالمنطقه ما سيربط عمليا بين
مليار وثلاثمائه مليون شخص بين ان البول
شاسع بين المامول والواقع اذ لا تزال
افريقيا تمتلك ادنى مستوى للتجاره البينيه
بين قارات العالم الى حدود اليوم هناك
صراعات سياسيه هناك حدود مغلقه هناك حروب
اهليه هناك اراده
تعاكسها التوجهات هذه الوثيقه وبالتالي هي
تعمل على اضعاف تنزيلها على ارض الواقع او
على الاقل الابطال تنزلها على ارض الواقع
ولكن اذا راينا
اقليميا التعاون على المستوى الافريقي
فهناك بعض المناطق قد نجحت في تطوير
التعاون اقتصادي اقترب من روح هذه الوثيقه
وبمنطق الربح والخساره تتخوف الدول الاقل
نموا من خسائر في عائدات الرسوم الجمركيه
لصالح الدول الاكثر نموا اضافه الى الفساد
وبروقراطيه الاداره وضعف الانظمه الماليه
وتباينها في عدد من الدول بالاضافه لتطوير
البنى التحتيه يطمح المغرب الى تجسيد
التكامل الافريقي عبر اطلاق مشاريع واحده
كانبوب نقل الغاز النيجيري وتوفير السماد
الزراعي بالاعتماد على الفوسفاط المختار
العلاوي الجزيره الرباط